ibm cloud satellite infrastructure
service
the latest version of ibm mq and new
field guides for ibm operations
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all
my name is ian and i am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements
from ibm cloud to start things off this
week
let's take a look at the all new ibm
cloud satellite infrastructure service
which essentially allows you to have
public cloud in your data center
on flexible fully managed as a service
infrastructure
satellite infrastructure service allows
you to modernize your application safely
before migrating them to the public
cloud it also allows you to modernize
parts of your data center stacks
without breaking these legacy
application interdependencies
best of all you can have peace of mind
when it comes to satellite
infrastructure service
on-prem infrastructure it's
pre-architected validated
optimized and fully managed by the
industry leader in managed i.t services
us ibm cloud satellite infrastructure
service brings ibm public cloud to your
data center
on fully managed paper use
infrastructure providing you financial
and technological flexibility to learn
more about the new service check out the
blog link i've put below
in the description of this video next up
let's take a look at the new version of
ibm mq 9.2.3
mq facilitates the exchange of
information within
and across hybrid cloud multi-cloud
microservices
and serverless applications the new
version helps you accelerate digital
transformation
by supercharging the value of existing
data enabling native high availability
and simplifying hybrid multi-cloud
management
this release provides several key new
features including streaming cues
native high availability and mq console
remote queue manager support
the release also contains a number of
important improvements and updates to
existing features
so hit the link below for the full
rundown
to wrap things up today i want to
introduce two new ibm architecture field
guides for ibm operations
these field guides are handy
introductions to applying ibm's
agile service management operations
methodology to your organization
and streamlining your processes the
first one is the ibm cloud service
management and operations field guide
this documents our approach to designing
implementing and continuously improving
the operations management processes you
use in your enterprise
the second is the all new ibm ai ops
field guide
this one documents our approach to the
infusion of artificial intelligence
into existing operational processes
including incident
problem and change management each of
these field guides are free to download
and you can find the links in the blog
i've got linked below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered
make sure you explore the links in the
description of this video and again
please don't forget to subscribe to our
channel to stay up to date on what's
going on in the cloud
now
you